the stuff we used to smoke had seeds
in fact it was a ritual where you clean
the weed
on an album cover and and then you
collect the seeds one time i i had my
uh house in in bel air remodeled
and i used hippie labor and so the
hippies when they were there they smoked
a couple of pounds of weed
and they cleaned it and they left the
seeds
at my house and so the my uh house the
guy that was looking after my house he's
uh italian from italy uh
he found the seeds and so i had an area
in my yard that went up the hill and it
had a natural spring
and so he planted all the seeds up there
i had a i had he had over 40 plants
up there in bel air and they grew to be
15 feet
tall and the best oh the
juiciest bud and the neighborhood the
neighborhood kids got a whole
wind of it you know and so this one kid
used to sneak in the yard and
and steal the some of the bud
and so frank uh he's like i say he was
from italy
frank he saw that that was happening so
he stayed up there one night
with his gun he had a gun a handgun and
the kid comes and steals the weed and
he's
trying to make it away and frank got him
from behind
hey you you must stop you stopping you
dropping that bag or i'm gonna shoot the
you in the ass
and i'll tell you when you tell a guy
where you're going to shoot him
that's how you know that's that's when
it gets serious the guy
kid dropped the bag and he ran and so
the next day
frank told me about that and so i said
you know this is dangerous you know i
don't want anybody getting killed over
my weed
and so i went down to the frank told me
where the kid came from
and as i walked up to the house there's
a loud rock and roll music playing you
know
when i knocked on the door the music
stopped
and then the dad came to the door and i
said
he said yeah can i help you i said yeah
i said listen tell your kid to stay out
of my yard don't be
don't be stealing weed you know
stealing my plants he said what is it
what what what plants is he stealing is
marijuana he said isn't that illegal
and i said yeah i said that's another
reason why you should stay away from my
my plants and the father goes i'll tell
them
thanks so much for watching this clip
and if you drink
coffee you need a mug shot
mug that's my first ever mug shot and
this mug is available on amazon as well
as at stevo.com
so go ahead and click the link in the
description below this is what you're
going to
and grab yourself a mug shot mug
yeah dude yeah
dude